you know there's a lot of depressing
news out there and we're trying to
figure out what the lead what the lead
of this show is going to be you got the
Kerry Lake election contest lawsuit has
advanced a judge had a trial date you
got Tick Tock and a pair of lawmakers
bipartisan plus Rubio they want to ban
it in the United States so this is
bipartisan you got Elon Musk they put
the story saying they haven't paid rent
in weeks which which means what it's
like oh no I haven't paid my mortgage in
a month yeah well that's how it works
you pay it every month so I don't know
what that story is but I need a good
laugh today I need I needed to have fun
we needed to laugh and there's the story
where Joe Biden who's 80 years old
explodes cussing saying you think I
don't know how I think old I am yelling
because they're like bro you're too old
you can't run for president 2024 but
he's gonna do it anyway so um you know
we can we can laugh at that I guess Joe
Biden exploding and getting angry about
it there's a lot to talk about before we
get started head over to simcast.com
become a member in order to support our
work and you'll get access to exclusive
members only uncensored segments of this
show Monday through Thursday at 11 PM
and I will also add that next week we
will be in Phoenix we're gonna be doing
the show live with Turning Point USA so
it may be we got to figure out exactly
how it's going to go down it may be
earlier than we normally do the show
because we're gonna be on stage at the
event and uh we're gonna have a
different guests come in and out it'll
be a whole lot of fun and and then we'll
be in Phoenix for that week and then
Christmas so um I think we might be off
after Christmas because literally nobody
wants to travel and work between
Christmas and New Year so we'll see what
happens but again go to timcast.com
become a member smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share this
show with your friends we got a couple
guests joining us to talk about this and
so much more we got Riley Moore
thanks for having me who are you good
sir I am the state treasurer of West
Virginia and uh I'm also a candidate for
congress in 2024 in the great state of
West Virginia right on you also skate
better than beta O'Rourke uh that is a
fact and if somehow this is able to
transmit over to him I will play him in
a game of skate anywhere anytime uh he
can't win elections and he certainly
cannot win a game of skate against it
yeah but but in all fairness like we
were just downstairs the mini ramp and
you're actually doing a bunch of tricks
you did like a fakie pivot Rock and like
kickflips and stuff Beto like rides on
the board and acts like he's cool so
it's just it's just it's just punching
down you know so yeah yeah but Phil's
back too hi everybody I am uh Phil
Labonte I sing for the heavy metal band
All That Remains uh I am here to enjoy
the uh wonderful Maryland air and I'm
here to be loud with Luke and Tim and
hang out with Riley so we can dunk on
loser Beto and Biden yeah you know we
can that's I I'm so happy we decided to
go with the Biden's old story and in
reality don't you know I haven't heard
that one before don't you think I know
how
first of all I don't believe that he
knows
all right let's save it for the actual
the answer is no
chilling hey
hey what do Christmas lights and Jeffrey
Epstein have in common well you're gonna
have to find out on
thebestpoliticalshorts.com where you can
get the sweater that I'm wearing right
now where you could also get long
sleeves v-necks women shirts you name it
socks we got it all on
thebestpoliticalshirts.com perfect for
your next family gathering because you
guys buy these shirts that's why I'm
here thank you so much for having me
good to see you guys it'll be a good
show
what was that yeah he's gonna be angry
yeah he's gonna be pissed was that
Afrikaans you yeah I'm just saying uh
good to be on the podcast
there you go man all right here's the
first story we have from The Daily Mail
uh I don't know Phil do you want to just
read the headline because no we think
you don't have any idea
old man
uh you think I don't know how [ __ ]
old I am Joe Biden 80 says
vents to our lives about how he's fed up
with fixation on his age as Democrats
speculate if he will run for president
in 2024. this one actually is really
funny uh Biden turned 80 in November
he'd be 82 82 years old if he wins and
takes office in 2025 he is already the
oldest man ever elected president I'm
pretty sure if Trump wins he would also
be the oldest president ever elected yep
so I guess this is just where we're at
what is this look I guess maybe we just
want to rag on Joe Biden a little bit
but yes
but the question I have is why is it
that old people are clinging to power
like this and where are the younger
people to to cling it back and actually
start leading I I guess you're running
Riley you're younger yeah look I younger
than Biden but yeah most people alive
are yeah
[Laughter]
um Truth uh you know for me look I won
this office as state treasure from an
older guy he had been in office for 24
years was elected in 1996 uh and uh look
we that's what we Reign on I ran on
modernizing the office changing the
office bringing it into uh this Century
um which he was like I did modernize the
office in 1996 we got the internet uh
can you really say that yes uh so bless
his heart yes that's all you can say is
that poor man but you know to your point
them clinging to power I'm the first
Republican elected in West Virginia as
State Treasurer in 92 years
and this is West Virginia and it's you
know people just Clinging On to first
elected uh first Republican elected in
92 Years first Republican elected 92
years wow and you know I mean it does
take this generation stepping up and
taking some risks that was a risk for me
I'm taking the risk here to run for
Congress in 24. and uh yeah I mean it
just takes this generation to just step
up and do something about it because if
you don't I mean if you don't keep
taking shots at kind of the uh
establishment class yeah they will
continue to persist we do have uh Ocasio
Cortez you know yeah yes he's Millennial
yes are do you count as a millennial or
are you a Gen X I'm Gen X I think I'm
right on the border yeah because I'm 42
you said yeah so 1980 and depending what
the internet says sometimes I'm Gen X
sometimes I'm um I think I call it
zenial yeah yeah Ian's the same age I
just wonder if
people that are Gen X
generally we've kind of been fairly the
aloof and detached generation like
people didn't hear a whole lot about Gen
X like
Millennials kind of stormed onto the
scene before people started paying
attention to Gen X it was like everyone
was complaining about the Boomers we
were kind of just quietly you know
existing and then the Millennials came
and were just like pay attention to me
foreign
and uh the you know Gen X is kind of
like
you know and I wonder if that's if that
kind of attitude of being aloof is kept
Gen X
away from trying to be in in government
I'm I'm this is kind of I guess
spitballing here I think jet X is like
the Forgotten generation kind of because
everyone everyone's mad at Boomers and
disgusted by Millennials and Gen X is
just like right we're here too guys
correctly exists I I just go to work
every day you know that's the thing like
whenever I bring up Boomer stuff I'll
say like you know the Boomers did this
good the this bad and the Millennials
are doing this I get a bunch of comments
where they're like Tim I'm Gen X We
Exist I'm like I know I know it's just
there's not really much to say because
you're doing all right yeah right that's
right you got some good music uh you're
you're running some companies you're not
doing horrible things boomers are doing
you didn't make Star Trek the Next
Generation but you maybe worked on it
with the Boomers but you're also not a
bunch of psychopaths for the most part
so I'm chill with Gen X I think they're
cool people for the most part Gen X has
been has been uh fairly benign and right
and inoffensive aside from the fact that
stop generalizing and collectivizing I I
just wanna I just want to bring it back
to this uh This original story here
because uh Biden still thinks he's in
charge here uh obviously clearly there's
bigger powers above him that do call the
shots here but we have to consider that
with the way that the Democratic party
is shaping up and even sources coming
out through the corporate media saying
that he's going to announce his bid for
the presidency after uh this holiday
season there's a big chance that he
actually might run and he might win
especially with the way that the
Democrats have been fortifying elections
I think it's it's very clear more than
ever that we could have a second Biden
Administration especially with the
advancements of Technology especially
with how useful he has been to the
current ruling class that has been using
him in order to push on the most
unpopular policies ever on Humanity
especially with the way that they have
played out destroying domestic energy
and I could go on and on and on but it's
a deliberate action I think he's there
for a reason and I think he might be
there for the next six years Luke you're
exciting the doomers hey hey I'm being
real here hold on you know I just gotta
we remember the photo where Biden had
the the IV track marks or whatever yes
they're they're they're they're cranking
him full of whatever he's on stem cells
young people baby blood probably they do
it in Mexico don't joke here this is not
crazy stuff they literally do this stuff
uh in some places around the world uh
some people might say adrenicarm some
people might say this hey okay that's
another but but the Redstone but the
stem cells and the young people blood is
not out of uh the realm of possibility
here we've got to slow down a little bit
you said baby blood and adrenochrome
hold on
some people might say adrenochrome I
said baby blood it's okay but it's
probably what we have heard is these
stories where powerful Elites hire like
19 year old bodybuilders to do blood
transfusions every other week black boys
I mean that's the joke Silicon Valley
but yeah right right yeah you know so I
don't know what they're cranking Biden
full of but we saw the IV marks he's an
old guy at the very least he's getting
like a vitamin drip they probably come
in drip yeah once a week they hook up
the IV and they give him you know
vitamin C vitamin B all that stuff
listen look they bring in a Brina Mitch
right they close in the room they start
getting all the liquids from all the
human body bodily orifices and then they
start summoning the the entities and
then they this probably literally
happens and they probably are like keep
him in power he's too good for us and
the demons are like okay yes we'll do
this translated that's probably what's
happening translate into English what
really happens he flies back to Delaware
a lot he probably is going in there so
they can bring in doctors that they
don't track the doctor then brings a
vitamin drip IV bag maybe NAD you know
if you watch Joe Rogan you know exactly
what's going on and they're probably
stem cells definitely stem cells is
actually like like I don't want to say
common I want to I want to submit one
quick idea Before Before I Let You Go On
I I don't think you're right because I
believe all that stuff that you're
talking about works and Joe Biden
doesn't Fair Point fair point but it's a
certain age at a certain age though I
mean there's only so much you could do
to fix the system I mean you could keep
him up and running but but you know with
the way that things are going and the
way that truly things are run in our
political system why wouldn't he have a
body double why wouldn't the body double
be in there when he's so convenient for
the ruling class I mean I think that's
worth speculating on I don't have any
proof I don't have any evidence of this
but if the president of Venezuela has a
body double why wouldn't the U.S
president have a body double no I I
definitely agree with that they they
there was like that Viral photo that of
Hillary Clinton that everyone said
wasn't really Hillary Clinton and I'm
like like I don't know I'm not gonna get
in it but she did not look like Hillary
Clinton if you're a powerful military
military involved or state official yeah
I really doubt the U.S would not give
you a body double yeah Kim Jong-un has a
couple of them right and the United
States doesn't have of them come on I
want all that to be true I don't know
that I believe it but it's a much cooler
story than like not having body doubles
I don't I don't I don't know that I see
I have seen any kind of evidence that
would lead me to believe that but I mean
well I also you know I there's a lot of
things that I that the government has
done that I would not have right right
Riley's got like two or three body
doubles yeah that's right in West
Virginia state treasure I I need one to
come and do 360 Flip for me that's right
but uh the the thing is though for the
left he is the best candidate he's the
greatest candidate they can have because
he believes in essentially whatever they
tell him to believe yeah he's an
engineer and all he's ever wanted his
life in his entire life was to be
president he's ran several times he's
there this is the retirement gig and
talking about Millennials well the White
House is chocked full of them and they
are running the show every left-wing
thing that you can think of has been
pushed forward by this Administration I
mean it makes almost like the Obama
Administration look like moderate
Administration compared to what's
happening right now in the body we had
that we had that viral video of the
biggest Caravan ever to cross the
southern border and it's just it's kind
of crazy to me that you can be politely
and calmly saying something like hey
it's really bad that there's a bunch of
kids living under a bridge and dying in
the desert and being trafficked and
young girls being raped and coyotes in
Black Market
and just nothing happens
so why what are important things going
on he literally said that are you going
to go to the Border no because there's
more important things going on I just
want to finish my point so why wouldn't
they keep this kind of show running when
it's so beneficial to them and second I
met someone that looks exactly like me
and I was like I need your number hold
on I might need you in the future and if
I'm thinking this way what is the U.S
federal government thinking about I mean
it's you look at Face-Off you look at
the advancements in plastic surgery
artificial intelligence anything yes you
look at it hey
I'm saying anything is possible here I
mean if you're bringing Obama you do an
operation I mean I mean I want to say
that I want to say that it's silly but
if you go and you read history about the
things that the CIA has actually tried
and attempted they'll try anything
incapacitated was not able to rule but
his wife was ruling with the special
interest with the people behind him they
were making all the decisions
Reagan's brain was gone exactly so this
happened before why wouldn't it happen
now why wouldn't it happen during the
second Administration it's like uh you
know that that vacation movie with
Bernie what's his name weekend at Bernie
yeah it's like we get him Bernie's two
they made they made it to the second
version so there's the likelihood that
there's going to be another version of
this do you think there's any point
where he's brought some issue or policy
and he says no
I I mean by his yes yes but they
probably he probably tries to say no and
goes and then they're just lying it's
good he like they take his hand with a
rubber step and he's like roll and then
they stamp yes
I can't do anything about it I don't
think that I don't think he has any care
about any of the policies that are being
presented at all yo they put him they
put him in a fake office remember when
he was young he was at a sound stage and
it screens behind him and they're like
that's right you're the president and
he's like
yeah I don't think he does I think that
I think that you know there's not a
whole lot of argument that your
decisions are being made without Biden's
input there's you know most people think
that the they're the chief of staff and
and other people in the administration
are actually making the day-to-day calls
and then the overall broad policy
decisions are not being made by by Joe
Biden because the overall broad policy
decisions are kind of kind of baked into
the philosophy that the left has now you
know it's like you kind of can predict
what the policy positions they're going
to be looking for the the the things
that the activists are acting for are
asking for the uh the you know the
people in in positions of Power are
doing their best to deliver to the
activists I just got to make sure people
know like whenever I say something crazy
I gotta pull up a source because I
remember we had one time that uh uh Luke
mentioned Bill Gates was creating uh
computer chips to implanting people to
stop him from getting pregnant and I was
like oh come on Luke that's and then we
Googled it and it was true so we have
this from the New York Post Biden mocked
for Truman's show presidency over fake
White House set that's right they put
Biden in a in a set with TV screens as
fake windows and they put different
things on the back that's what they're
doing to this man I just want to make
sure everybody knows that actually
happened that we know of they do just
you know they're going to keep rolling
them out and if you go flash back to
Biden 20 years ago Biden 30 years ago
whatever it is different guys different
guy policies were very very different
now he's abortion with no limits
whatsoever uh but in a not too distant
past that's not where he was they have a
fake White House set why wouldn't they
have a fake White House President right
I'm serious I'm surprised they didn't
work with Disney and and started uh one
of the rides where it's like you know
one of the rides in Disney where you
just kind of sit there and then the
theater kind of moves like here's now
the president of the United States and
you get the AI generated hologram puppet
coming out there that's literally
something that could be conceivable and
could be happening right now especially
because when you look at Mill Terry
technology it is usually 30 years ahead
of what's in the general public usually
knows about but the point that we've
been like the the thing that we're kind
of saying is it doesn't matter if it's
Joe but like if Joe Biden has a body
double or not because Joe Biden isn't
making the calls anyways yeah so if it's
the in if it's Joe Biden or a body
double of Joe Biden it doesn't matter
because we've already kind of agreed
that the chief of staff at the White
House is making the calls and the actual
Direction the left is going is going
that way without Joe Biden and Joe
Biden's just along how many times has he
said something publicly and then they
come out and correct it exactly I mean
multiple times that's why that's why I
don't think a lot we've argued this
before people are like he's clearly not
making the call someone's doing it for
him and I'm like no no I think he is but
they're just shrugging and then doing
random things so when he goes on TV and
says a thing
they have to come out and correct them
now think about what happens behind
closed doors he's telling them what to
do and then they're doing whatever they
want so I don't think they're going to
Biden and saying Biden you're going to
tell people to do this and he goes okay
I think they go in and Biden goes all
right here's what we're going to do
we're going to do this that better than
they're like you got it and they walk
out and say what are you guys going to
do I'm gonna do something else
yeah and I think they do have to and
they've been trying to do this they're
trying to manage him better I mean do
you remember when he came out and said
red line with Taiwan China invades
Taiwan we're showing up and they're like
oh hey uh timeout here's actually what
he meant yeah or when he said they're
going to get mad at me if I read this or
ask questions so everyone's like who's
they yeah who's the president
just like you said like it's all this is
all evidence just you know that that he
isn't the guy in charge that there are
other people that will correct the
president now that's not the way it's
supposed to be but it doesn't matter if
it's him or a body double or whatever
considering that is the open and kind of
obvious State of Affairs regardless of
whether people approve of it or not you
don't I mean it doesn't matter if people
that like Biden don't like the fact that
Biden doesn't make calls everyone
[ __ ] knows Biden doesn't make the
call pardon my friendship it's it's not
just that it's it's when he starts to
understand like oh here's the media let
me talk to them they literally whisk him
away there's a video of an Easter Bunny
appearing grabbing Joe bidening him away
when he was starting to talk about
Afghanistan knowing oh crap that he
can't talk to the media Fox News Easter
Bunny whisks Biden away as he starts
discussing Afghanistan video that's a
real thing that happened and literally
we are having hired actors Easter
Bunnies acting like the media Liaisons
making sure that the president of the
United States does not get to openly
speak with the press and and the media
you can't script this stuff look at this
video Let's play it look at what's he
doing
[Music]
[Laughter]
literally whisked them away like nope
not happening that is crazy who's in
charge it's not Joe Biden that should
get played every time that that Joe
Biden speaks that should be played right
afterwards so everyone knows exactly
what the score is and all you could kind
of make out was like Pakistan
Afghanistan they're like did he say
Pakistan let Easter Bunny yeah let's get
over there the Easter Bunny standing
there and then like looking around and
then you know CIA guy is like or FBI the
president's going off script bringing
the Easter Bunny and the Easter Bunny is
like copy copying these money like goes
in waving and but for real that's
probably what happened yes that's
literally what happened they had someone
had to tell the Easter Bunny to go and
stop him from speaking to people
can you imagine in his mind he's like
God these people are everywhere
I finally got away I finally could speak
to the Press I finally get to say
something no the Easter Bunny comes in
you guys ever watch like Mr Magoo yeah
where he's like blindly bumbling about
and then he like walks on the I-beam and
gets lifted up and then Walks Like We
need something like that of Biden I mean
it's like the CIA being like Oh
he's on the move I mean you could just
take Biden's face and put it onto an
existing cartoon of of Mr Magoo doing
all that stuff and it would fit fine
I've always been a fan of the ghost
handshakes you know he turned yeah
thank you it's funny because I feel like
uh I always reference what was it um
what was the movie where the where the
the person's riding the the gravity bomb
down like yeah that goes out of the
plane or whatever uh
yeah that's what it kind of feels like
you know when we're sitting here
laughing about what Biden is we're like
that's so funny and it's like
everything's on fire and we're
surprising about how funny it is it's
like uh maybe we should be I don't know
I guess what can you do you can laugh
you can laugh every cry yeah there's a
cry about it 100 there's a lot of people
that you know get upset about things
that they read and stuff and it's like
look you can be angry about it but it's
not gonna change it like you so are you
getting upset about something that you
saw on the Internet isn't going to
change the conditions in the world one
bit and I I mean like I'm not super
stoic but I do like follow like stoicism
pages and that's one of the things that
Stokes talk about like only let the
things that you can actually change
affect you and like the things that you
can't change like just try not to let
them ruin your day because you can't do
anything about them you know you what I
think uh you want to just focus on
building your skills
uh get learn some outdoors kind of stuff
I'm not telling you to become a prepper
survivalist I'm saying you know learn
how to make a fire I'm saying become a
prepper survivalist I'm saying with the
way things are going and especially with
what the pope has been saying especially
with the way that everything is moving
become a survival and what'd the pope
say the pope said that he had an omen of
even greater destruction and desolution
for mankind I want to say that I was
raised Catholic and as far as I know
Catholics getting Omens is some demonic
kind of stuff that is like heresy or
like that like that's blasphemy I don't
think that Catholics are supposed to be
getting Omens that's like yeah well this
is the lgbtq woke Pro immigration Pope
as well that's a weird Catholic but you
know yeah he's the woke Pope so
um but again I don't think his
assessment is wrong especially if you
look at how international relations are
shaping up especially when you look at
the larger Financial picture especially
when you look at the overall health and
population decline in Crash that's
coming I think he's absolutely really I
don't know anything you guys should
prepare you guys should be smart you
guys should be making moves in your life
where you're becoming the strongest best
versions of yourselves because you will
be tested and hard times are ahead of us
there's no denying this because we are
having too many weak men creating really
bad times those bad times are going to
be upon us very soon have you guys
watched the show the peripheral I have
so there it's like there's they call the
jackpot when all of the like all of the
problems that everyone's talking about
happen all at once basically over the
span of a few years and I think they
were saying like it starts in 2028 with
the Texas secessionist movement or
something obviously they're they're
being inspired by the news and stuff
we're seeing today but it was it was
interesting to see nonetheless that
maybe there's some kind of potential
there that the fourth turning suggests
2028 is the crescendo or whatever it may
be 2026 because 2028 is when it's
supposed to stop or something like that
or who knows I don't know if those
predictions are completely true it's
just people have ideas but considering
what we're seeing around us I'm seeing
every so often you'll get you'll get
some commenter commentator be like oh
you know what I realize things aren't
really that bad and then you see like
project Veritas expose a school for
passing around adult toys to children
and then
politically people like the school is
actively defending it saying it's okay
and I'm like all right you know that's
the demonic stuff because when you're at
the point where the school is like you
know what we're not even gonna try and
hide it anymore we're going to outright
just defend it the outright defend it
it's like we're off the line we're over
the cliff We Are Free Falling at this
point so I don't feel like 2026 is too
too big a an ask to say that's when
things you know pop up I'm not saying
literally ask I'm saying it's not too
too uh far of a uh too far-fetched to
believe yeah absolutely not I mean I
started my own prepper apocalypse class
online I started doing them in New
Hampshire and a lot of people were
really interested in it because I I
think you know even if it's not you know
political disasters I mean the chances
of natural disasters are also out there
the the the chances of just something
bad happening is always out there no
matter what being prepared for it makes
you not only have peace of mind but but
also has you ready for almost anything
coming your way and I think this is the
kind of mentality that could actually
Safeguard us a lot of stress have us not
freak out have us not lose our ish but
also more importantly Go Back To Nature
and understand the importance of
personal responsibility taking care of
ourselves and not needing a government
to step in and have a food delivery or a
water purification delivery system but
having that in place already where if
times do get really hard you won't need
more government you will need more space
you will need more freedom and I think
once we incentivize that and start
pushing those larger ideas out there uh
Society by and large will become better
because of that well and that's actually
an interesting part of the show right
kind of post jackpot it's massive
massive government control right I mean
they're controlling I mean literally
what people think what happens in
society and I mean to your point on the
prepper side and this is something I've
been working on in the state treasurer's
office I'm sure you've seen these MCC
codes they're putting in place for
credit cards now to be able to track the
purchase of guns and ammunition around
the country this is a back door uh
National gun registry and this was
pushed by Elizabeth Warren and the Raz
so if you are buying guns right now pay
cash or uh check but this is something
that we're going to have legislation on
in January in West Virginia hopefully
other states are replicated and and it's
actually not the credit card companies
that want to track this it's the banks
the banks want to track it and then the
banks are going to be able to say oh
we're going to flag this so you're going
to flag that you're saying that I got a
Discover card for no reason uh
as soon as the news came out that was
like visa and MasterCard I was like I'm
gonna apply for a Discover Card we're
gonna use it for business stuff yeah I
got one I got it right here I'm holding
it I don't want to show it because it's
credit card obviously yeah and I mean it
is you know visa and MasterCard I mean
they're they're held to the whims of
these Banks and it was big Bank in New
York that have been pushing this and it
has like some Anodyne name the I think
it's the international organization on
standardization
one of the good things about the the gun
culture is the people that are that tend
to be selling guns and firearms and
stuff like that they're usually very
open to cash they're very you know right
sometimes they're open to barter even
but definitely open to cash
um so or 3D printed guns you do it
yourself work too I mean yeah there's
nothing wrong with with printing Guns by
the parts that aren't serialized over
through mail order or whatever and then
you know when it comes to the actual
receiver or whatever yeah just make sure
because I think what was it the ATF was
cracking down on the what what was it
called well there's like you could buy a
kit where it's like all the stuff that
you legally have to have tracked is
tracked and then you can assemble it
yourself but they're like 80 kits or
something like that and then the ATF
started claiming that it was you
couldn't do it you're coming after
people you can buy a whole rifle except
for the lower receiver which is the part
that serialized that has the gun so you
have everything the upper receiver all
of the pins and and everything you need
you can buy that without any kind of uh
any kind of background check during
check or anything like that and then you
can either print a lower receiver or you
can buy it depends on what state you're
in as well because there's oh yeah
I'm talking about where you will get in
trouble for it so make sure you always
look up the local laws and jurisdictions
to make sure that you're not entrapping
yourself or your friends or your buddies
with some activities that you could be
maybe bragging about on social media
which you should you shouldn't do it the
the when I what I was talking about was
Federal Regulation not State regulated
yeah so I won't point out in state of
West Virginia there's not too much you
can't do uh that's right yeah in terms
of guns constitutional carry oh yeah
Maryland's one of the few states that
actually banned uh flamethrowers which
is insane it's crazy and California
I guess they were worried about you know
Baltimore and and the DC burbs with
people walking around flames and if I
understand correctly the flamethrower in
question the one that Elon made was was
selling or that caused it was actually
the same kind of uh flamethrower they
used for tarring uh roofs yeah I guess
that you have to have a thing to heat up
the tar or something on a roof and
you'll use that to heat it up so it was
our an existing tool that you know Elon
just put a you know Market in and you're
like oh you can't have that because it's
scary to me now but you know I mean to
your point though I mean some level of
individual I mean Independence out there
I mean I think it is important I mean
you know we're talking about the banks
and tracking the gun purchases they
tried to put into uh that big Bill Green
New Deal 2.0 was that uh tracking the uh
600 purchases or greater uh and they
were going to legislate that well then
the bite Administration just turned
around made that a rule yep right so
that's a rule now and I mean that is a
tremendous amount of oversight so it was
like okay we'll take that out of the
bill we'll get the 87 000 new IRS agents
into the bill and now we'll just make a
rule so we started that segment talking
about a big Easter Bunny and it's a
ridiculous segue but we have this from
vice.com Elon Musk is now promoting Q
Anon they say since 2018 the saying
follow the white rabbit has become
synonymous with Q Anon musk has tweeted
a version of that year 2018.
is that what I said uh so Elon Musk
tweeted follow and then a bunny Emoji
it's an Alice in Wonderland reference he
he history started in 2018 though well
of course yeah I mean that's when the
simulation began we just had false
memories and playing the Dennis still an
explanation so uh this is where we're
currently at let me put it this way let
this be a tremendous white pill
the media is so desperate so panicked
the corporate process so Panic to go
after Elon Musk they have to take this
follow and a rabbit emoji which could be
a matrix reference and then try and
claim he's promoting Q Anon oh dude it's
amazing they may as well just say he
started gamergate at this point
yeah that was Elon history started in
2018 like you were saying it's like they
don't have nothing to attack him on so
they're just starting to make things up
out of nowhere to generate clicks that
is exactly the case I mean think if
you're in their position this is like a
nightmare scenario
yeah I mean it's all I mean you've seen
the Twitter files coming out and all
that uh I mean it's it's everything that
we knew but now it's obviously been
substantiated through these Twitter
files and I mean I I'm sure they are
freaking out
um so yeah I mean they're gonna throw
anything at the ball that can stick but
does anybody buy this
it's like just the insanity I mean do
they all know they're lying you're like
every single one of these Twitter
leftists they're like yeah that's right
it's queuing on like they have to know
their line I imagine there's so there's
a portion of them that believe it you
know just like they're a portion of on
the right that believe whatever crazy
thing you know anyone could come up with
from from the right but I think mostly
it's a functional way to smear Elon Musk
it's just you know spaceship man bad
right now because of this article
they're going to put in his Wikipedia
page he's a conspiracy theorist who
promoted Fringe theories blah blah blah
they'll go ahead and they'll they'll
it'll be ideal laundering you know he
puts up the White Rabbit so they say
that it's queuing on and then someone
else will say it's Q Anon referencing
that just like they do you know ideal
laundering and reference each other and
then next thing you know what it goes
into is is Wikipedia and Elon Musk is
then you know the Q Anon space that's a
great thing Spaceman a space shipment
I'm tweeting that take a look at this
story this one's really really funny
Daily Mail says breaking news Twitter
has stopped paying rent on San Francisco
offices as Elon Musk considers not
paying Severance to axed employees now
when you hear that you're like whoa whoa
that's crazy
let me let me break it down for you it
says Twitter has allegedly not paid rent
on its San Francisco headquarters or
office around offices around the world
for weeks
week it's been it's it's been December
for two weeks yeah so he hasn't paid
rent for weeks yeah because you pay on
the first I I haven't either oh no I
haven't paid my mortgage in a month
because it's due the end of the month
it's like oh it's been it's been three
weeks this is the level of insanity for
smearing Elon it doesn't matter if it's
news or not it's just can we make can we
create a narrative that sounds negative
it's so weird
they just I mean it's not that weird if
you think remember remember the way that
that any way any time a negative
headline could be written about Trump
they did the the koi pond thing you know
it's any time you can write a negative
headline they edited video footage to
make that story right yep so the koi
Bond thing Trump is hanging out with
Shinzo Abe Abe dumps the food in and
then Trump goes okay and then dumps his
in as well but they zoom in so you only
see Trump and then said haha what an
idiot he threw all the food in and then
when you look at the unedited video you
can see he was just following Shinto
Abe's lead and they made up a fake story
but they actually tried to make up some
decorum violation with this it's just
like he hasn't paid rent in weeks and
they all start saying it and then I'm
seeing this from everybody they were
like in weeks
is he doing a weekly lease on his
buildings he pays Weekly right what's
your point I don't understand but but
Tim you know Trump was also bad because
he had two scoops of ice cream if you
remember that I mean that was some
serious uh ethics violations right there
and I think he also walked into some
toilet paper I mean that's a guy that
needs to be stopped and he had bigger
salt and pepper shakers oh you see that
that's amazing and there are people who
say to this day Trump never denounced
white supremacists and neo-nazis I yeah
I know that you're right and it just
blows my mind
the the that the video of him saying
that is out it exists it's out there and
and it has been put onto Twitter saying
oh he never condemned them in response
so many times and they still oh he never
did there are still people I meet where
I say did you know that Joe Biden said
if you don't if you don't find the
prosecutor you're not getting a billion
dollars they go that never happened that
absolutely happens it's a video he says
it's literally in a in a like Think Tank
press conference on Foreign
Relations sitting there literally
talking to him on record on video and
he's like and people applaud Rachel
Maddow said it wasn't real and so people
just believe whatever she says without
even bothering to to look yeah that's
that's it's a crazy reality man
that's that that it's one of the
contributing factors to my simulation
Theory there's no way a functioning
sentient being would would just be like
you know I don't know if it's true but
it must be you know who do you know who
uh this is a bit of an off topic but do
you know who Adam and sich are they're
YouTubers they make they do a stream
show anyways they have this they talk
about this idea that most people
basically have the existence of like an
elephant and a rider and the Elephant is
your emotion and the rider is kind of
your brain that like makes the actual
decisions the writer can't really it's
still gonna do what it wants to do the
fight or flight like you can think but
if you're scared you're gonna fight or
flight
the guy on top thinks he's in charge but
he's not really he's the rider he's
actually kind of just the PR department
explaining rationalizing what the
elephant did so really most of our life
is our our cognitive ability
rationalizing the emotional reactions
that we have that's like most of the the
stuff that we you know most of our
behavior all the time here's the crazy
thing about the story is that 20 years
ago
it would all just be true you'd have no
way of checking it a newspaper would
write Elon Musk promotes Fringe
conspiracy theory and then you'd be like
must be true yeah that's it that's right
um you mentioned Rachel Maddow and we
did talk about body doubles is Chris
Hayes her body double no Michael
Knowles's okay
we actually have uh Smokey Mike right we
have uh we have drawings of all of our
guests and so when Michael Knowles came
Jessica the our artist here Drew Rachel
Maddow first yeah and so we're like here
when you sign this picture of you when
he hands he started laughing he signed
it we have it on the wall and then we're
like no no wait there's a real one sign
the real picture the real picture
yeah but uh I I am proud to say
snbc is is rated as fake news by
newsguard I am not surprised at all and
it's they should be absolutely and I
will say I know it's not a silver bullet
but when you're visiting your family for
Christmas or whatever you can at the
very least pull up on a browser or if I
don't know if there's a mobile app and
be alike guys
I don't know what you believe or why I'm
not going to argue with you I just want
you to know that News Guard says MSNBC
is beware it's fake news okay and
they're gonna go yeah well that was Fox
News and you can go uh-huh yeah I don't
know whatever I'm just telling you you
guys are watching weird conspiracy
garbage I'm not here to tell you what's
right or wrong I'm telling you be
careful with the weird conspiracy stuff
you're watching I was telling a friend
of mine he's like my family just watches
all this MSNBC and CNN and I was like
here's what you do when you're talking
you say I don't know about all that
political stuff if they start bringing
it up and be like guys you're listening
to Alex Jones and all this stuff and
when they invariably get really really
angry because they hate Jones what
you're trying to do is conflate in their
mind what they think of as conspiracy in
a way they understand it and accusing
them of doing exactly the same thing
yeah so you just like I would play it
off like look I don't know who Rachel
Jones or whatever it's that weird
conspiracy garbage you're watching on
the TV there's that that News Guard
thing they said it was conspiracy stuff
and you're watching it and then they get
let them get all flustered and just be
like I don't I don't know you guys go
watch your weird alien stuff your your
lizard people stuff I'm not I'm not
interested it makes me wish I had
in-laws to go and upset and then
and then when no one is watching no one
paying attention secretly put on died
suddenly and then act like you didn't do
it yourself but but more importantly
especially with the holiday season I
think we should expand on this topic
just a little bit before continuing on
the conversation here but but I think if
you truly do want to understand somebody
you got to do it from an empathetic kind
of way you gotta kind of understand
where they're coming from you got to
kind of listen to them and then you
could formulate a kind of response there
taking some time but you can only open
the door you could only uh you know put
out the water the horse has to drink it
themselves so I I think that's you know
my two cents when it comes to dealing
with family members who don't see eye to
eye to eye with you uh empathy and
understanding goes a long way also just
listening to people goes a very long way
and then you could understand why people
believe a certain idea a lot of it is
usually based on fear a lot of it is
usually based on kind of instincts and
emotions as you were mentioned you're
mentioning um and and not logical
thinking and if you could you could calm
down the emotions and you could not have
that kind of aggressive stance and you
could just say hey let's let's actually
reassess this maybe at a different time
or hey I don't know what to think about
this what do you think about this uh and
giving people that kind of information
that way could be a lot more conducive
towards waking people up towards the
true reality of this world rather than
the conceived closed notion that of
course the government wants them to have
there's a new song out by Paramore
and uh it's called the news
and in it Haley Williams is singing Turn
Off the news over and over again
my first reaction to hearing it was kind
of like what and then I went yeah she's
right
yeah I get it like we're the news too I
get it but uh there are a lot of people
who don't understand what they're
listening to and are being told a whole
bunch of weirdo nonsense garbage Rachel
Maddow did this segment where she was
like the Russians could turn off the
electricity the heat in Fargo and you
know kill people and it's like yeah they
could but that's there's like no reason
to believe that's actually going to
happen right now like why are you look I
like here's what here's here's what I I
do and I'm and we're not perfect like I
said we're the news too and so people
watch this stuff but uh we pull up news
stories about things that happened and
then talk about them
what shows like Maddow does is she
speculates and then just pushes whatever
Fringe Theory like the p-type stuff or
she would like Russia gate nonsense yeah
but then also comes to a conclusion on
it right exactly like like her own well
here's the truth I'm going to tell you
here's the conclusion oh and she's lied
so much like that viral video of her
talking about vaccines and transmission
yeah when she's like it stops with you
it's like you made that up
there was there was you know what man
they they all made it up I don't think
well I don't think that matto made that
up I think that Maddow just repeated
which is probably worse but it just she
just repeated what she was told because
there was absolutely no interest in
finding out if what we were told was
true it was just this is what the CDC
says then that is what must be the truth
there wasn't uh there was no room for
argument or debate about it so if you
push back on you know things like oh the
the the virus stops with you once you're
vaccinated if you push back on that I
mean you remembered that's the craziest
thing now so there's another thing I was
telling my friend I was like you don't
want to get into an argument with them
you know because like you're here for
the holidays Booth your family you know
what I mean if they want to press it you
got to be very very light with it yeah
and and I would say if that stuff comes
up just show them a New York state judge
said this does not stop transmission you
don't got to talk about you know
hearings and theories and the EU stuff
you'd be like I don't know there was a
judge in New York and there's official
ruling I don't know do you guys follow
the science that's what I like saying
you follow the science because the
science is is here you know you can you
can read it if you want I mean in terms
of the what drives their news and like
you said they all kind of get the same
talking points and memo there's no
easier job in Washington DC than being a
Democrat press secretary especially if
you're the White House person it's like
here's the talking points go forth and
they just cut and paste it and stick it
out there and that drives the narrative
no harder job than being a republican
press secretary uh because it's you
gotta convince and convince and I mean
but the Democrats I mean pretty sweet
gig it's not bad but let's let's talk
about uh uh Carey Lake because you know
I wanted to talk we got a bunch of
stories to go through but considering
we're still on the political angle let's
let's talk about Kayla we have the story
from AZ Central what's next for Lake
fincham election lawsuits hobbs's lawyer
calls challenges baseless so uh Carey
Lake filed the lawsuit contesting the
results of the election a judge today
called an emergency hearing they had
their emergency hearing the defense
which is Maricopa County Board of
Supervisors it's uh Katie Hobbs
Democrats basically said that they're
going to file a motion to dismiss but
the judge in the case set a trial date
for I believe uh let me see I think I
have the Tweet actually if we have it
there we go trial set for the 21st and
the 22nd this is kind of crazy it's
unfortunate it's going to be happening
over the holiday weekend but this could
be big so here's the difference between
this and Donald Trump's uh 2020 stuff
with Arizona you have a lawsuit from
Kerry Lake that points out well or they
make the claim they're 25
000 ballots that came in after election
day and that's greater than the margin
of Victory they want an evidentiary
hearing I don't know how you you you uh
how's the judge going to say no standing
he's going to say okay
show me the proof you have of this claim
they're going to file a motion to
dismiss it very well may get dismissed I
don't know the difference between this
and Trump to expand upon that is with a
lot of the lawsuits that were filed in
2020 the amount of votes that were being
challenged would not have overcome the
victory margin so the courts were just
like
this wouldn't matter if it happened
anyway so there's no point with Kerry
Lake 17 000 votes so if they can present
a variety of claims that are more than
17 000 and you do have in Maricopa
County they said when the voting
machine's malfunctioned 17 000 people
had to vote by this this Ballot Box
that's at bare minimum I think enough to
get well I don't know I mean like if you
were being an honest uh judge you'd be
like okay we have to have a review of
that if 17 000 ballots were were
affected by the machine's not working
and that's the margin of Victory we got
to do a review of those bouts otherwise
you know the election is gonna people
are gonna contest or whatever but uh I
think it's interesting nonetheless I
don't know what you guys think my
opinion is kind of that I'm not
convinced Carrie like going to be able
to overcome the swamp machine so I don't
think that there's I I think that
as much as she is is going to fight
tooth and nail because that's probably
her personality uh I don't think that
it's likely that she's going to be able
to overcome the fact that it was
already certified even though the
certification was you know dubious
because what's her name shouldn't be
certified Hobbs as a secretary of state
the Secretary of State should not be
certifying their own their own election
at all so that right there is dubious I
like but PolitiFact says it's totally
normal oh yeah I I I think that it's a
conflict of interest I think on its face
but I I think that like I don't think
that any of that stuff matters anymore
I've I've lost a lot of uh faith in the
electoral process so well I'm glad I'm
glad that she's filed suit I'm glad that
she's pursuing it and I think the Judge
absolutely should move
um they should go beyond a motion to
dismiss I mean you go back to the 2000
election right and we didn't have that
result that night and everyone's
freaking out how do we not know who the
president is now with these drop-off
ballots mail-in ballots ballot
harvesting all this I mean election
results taking weeks sometimes yeah it
is not instilling confidence in the
system whatsoever and then also the
question I'd want to know is
how do they determine when and which
ballots are getting cast you know I mean
is that kind of tip the scales a little
bit because maybe somebody calls a race
early
uh you know I I don't know but that you
have so many ballots sitting out there I
mean days and sometimes weeks after it
is it really puts uh pressure on the
system and I think it ruins confidence
out there in the lack in elections
Democrats completely broke the system
Republican established Republicans in
many places helped but the idea that
we're having election month and and
sometimes even election double month to
election two months because they're
doing a month early and then a month
after the count okay look man if we're
gonna have a functioning system there
have to be rules you can't just be like
the the Democrat position in the leftist
position is count all of the votes and
it's like no no no you count the votes
in the allotted time period And if you
can't then you've got to build a more
robust system to do so we have election
day the Constitution prescribes for
election day we can't be playing these
games where it's like well you know
we'll give it an extra week no no you
don't give it an extra week principally
I agree with with both of you
um like that's what I would like to see
I think the reality is on the ground uh
are about to prevent that I think yeah I
think that it's going to have to be
ballot harvesting I think it's going to
have to be the the conservatives are
going to have to react to the reality of
what elections are now and you were
talking earlier about you know people
being confident in elections and stuff I
think those days are long past like the
days of of Americans saying oh yeah
generally we feel good about our
election
that is a relics of an old time homie
that stuff is that stuff is gone that
was gone in it was probably gone in 2000
and we didn't realize it until uh I 16.
I blame YouTube largely I think so oh
definitely uh look you had half the
country voting one guy half the country
uh voting one guy or whatever whatever
you want to break it down and then
people have questions about what
happened they have ideas they have they
have complaints and then YouTube says
we're only going to allow one side of
the debate oh and so what happened then
is
that large group of people who believed
in Trump left the platform and stopped
communicating with the other side not
not by choice they were forced off
YouTube made sure and maybe it's on
purpose maybe they want everything to
implode or maybe they're just really
dumb
but by segmenting people in that way you
guarantee they entrench their views
never have a conversation it never
develops and then confidence will never
come back never this is what I was
taught when I was talking to Jack and
vagina video I said if you keep doing
what you're doing it's going to result
in some kind of conflict or Civil War or
something you cannot have two people in
an argument
separate them and tell them to keep
arguing about how bad the other side is
but only among themselves that is that
is how you entrench tribalism and it
results in otherism that's where we're
at and you radicalize people that way
exactly and you don't bring the country
together you separate people and you
perpetuate a divide and conquer agenda
which I believe has been festered and
organized deliberately but that's just
my kind of consensus and understanding
of the situation but I I do want to add
to your point Tim especially when it
comes to Big Tech social media because
overwhelmingly 18 to 30 year olds voted
for the Democratic party I do believe
that's because of Institutions like Tick
Tock like Twitter like Google like
Facebook like Instagram that of course
have been prioritizing particular
viewpoints that benefit them with the
political party that benefits them and
censoring the other political parties
that don't benefit them that do want to
have some kind of accountability when it
comes to these bigger institutions but I
think Florida here and shouts out to the
governor of Florida he's making some
very bold and brave Acts actions today
but but I think when we're looking at
Florida there are a lot of lessons to be
learned about the way that they handled
their elections their rules and they
also specifically Ron DeSantis
specifically made sure that Florida
would not be affected by the Zucker
bucks as he called it as Mark Zuckerberg
was financing hundreds of millions of
dollars into the voting effort which
predominantly helped Democrats uh get
more voters he made sure a lot of that
money didn't reach Florida it didn't and
I think it had an impact to it Florida
becoming uh so red and you knew that
result that night neglected results in
Florida that yeah 50 years ago we would
know the results on day one and now now
we it takes days and weeks how's that
possible how is that possible uh let's
see who is this uh Marty Smith
uh fan Sue superintendent saying in AZ
you can't file a dispute until
certification
so after Katie Hobb certifies then
Carrie like immediately launches the
lawsuit and and they made a lot there's
a lot of interesting uh claims made in
the lawsuit but people need to
understand
in a lawsuit you can claim anything you
want
so it's got to be adjudicated it's not
likely in my opinion that Kerry Lake
just made things up because then you get
to an evidentiary here and you're like
oh that's not true we made it up they're
going to be like okay then you lose so
I'm willing to bet they have something
to present I'd like to see it I I think
what's likely is the judge is just going
to be like I'm too scared of the far
left so I'm not going to actually per
you know let a real Fair hearing take
place but who knows the judge called an
emergency hearing and said we're doing
this they have till Thursday uh
Thursdays when their motion dismiss is
due then uh uh Carey Lake gets a
response on Saturday then then the
defendants get a response on Sunday and
then on Monday the judge will have a
hearing and then the trial date is the
21st and 22nd so this is crazy I think
he was like
he has like 10 days to issue a ruling on
this or something like some ridiculously
small amount of time and it's very very
difficult to go through all this it was
funny the uh the the Hobbs defense team
was like we all needed a half an hour to
argue to dismiss this and then Carrie
Lake's team was like no we need more
time than that and the judge was like
what about an hour each it's like I I
think that they're gonna wanna present a
lot of stuff but we'll see
I just also don't understand how okay
like this podcast being watched it all
over the world here we are in this room
they watch it all over the world we
don't have voting machines that work
like why do they keep having problems
with voting machines they can figure out
who uh we had that Powerball that was
like a two billion or whatever it was
right and they're like hundreds of
millions of tickets sold and they know
instantly who won yes now with these
elections though man ever but but to be
fair on that point it's because
everyone's fighting the the real battle
is man if if you thought elections were
won based on how many how many votes
someone got is very naive of you
elections are won based on the ground
game it's one based on the laws it's one
based on like so many components of this
signature verification mail-in ballots
you know when the ballots come in they
got to check signatures that changes the
way you know it's like it's like Joe
Biden said it's not about how many votes
you get about it's about who counts the
vote is that Joe Biden was it Joe Stalin
there's both okay it literally was both
yeah it actually was both it was both so
here we are this is the the current
state I guess you know a lot of people I
don't think care too much about the uh I
don't think as many people are following
this because the midterms have come and
gone and everyone's kind of zoned out
like exhausted from it
but while I'm not confident for Carrie
Lake and I'm a big fan I want her to win
I do think it would be really
interesting if she actually does win a
stay at the very least yeah and then
come January 2nd they're like oh we
actually can't we can't bring in you
know Hobbs as Governor because of the
stay you should buy Court
yeah I mean I'd like to I'd like to see
it just because I'd like to see the the
you know the non-establishment
um candidates win because I think the
establishment uh needs some fresh
refreshing
uh of idl's ideology I suppose
um but yeah I I don't I just don't see
her pulling it off I don't I don't see
the powers that be in in Arizona you
know well
I think I think maybe we're a bit
pessimistic because of what you know
we've seen in the past but uh I'm fully
likes fighting and so I'm rooting for
I'm rooting for it too I wanna I all I
want to see is the judge say show me the
evidence and then if they present bunk
garbage or it's weak and the judge says
I'm sorry it's not enough then I'm gonna
say well okay I guess but uh it needs to
get to that point because we haven't
seen that with these these other uh
lawsuits yeah yeah no standing get out
yeah they just get thrown out I mean
this one needs to go the distance and
look transparency is a good thing that
instills confidence let's have some
transparency in this and see actually
what happened to those 17 000 ballots
why the machines weren't working perhaps
what happened to those ballots they said
they were all counted yeah well I want
to know that they were all counted right
you know they they should do uh they
should they should go through and
signature verify whatever if and I'll
put it this way too let's say you
operate in the assumption that Carrie
like is just totally wrong then here's
your opportunity to prove it and rub it
in her face well in the annoying thing
is that because you're going through
this process or you believe this process
should happen the left is like election
denier you all are an election deniers
election tonight it's like no what we
want this is a good thing right however
it turns out this is a good thing that
could perhaps instill a little bit uh
more confidence in the electoral process
hopefully yeah as much as people as much
as the left says you know that there's
that election denial is bad and blah
blah blah blah they're doing everything
they can
to make sure that their opposition
doesn't have any faith in the in the
election they're throwing out all all
kinds of court cases saying without
standing they never get in front of a
judge they have they have all you know
they're saying that if you deny the
election or if you if you ask for
verification it's election denying
they're doing everything they can to
make people feel like the elections
should be suspect yeah well this is what
the left does with everything right it's
their solution is always worse than the
problem right so people had uh you know
there's voter suppression and people
don't have a confidence in elections so
now we're gonna have elections last for
a month right and it's just it made it
worse it just made things even worse it
just made things even worse I mean it's
like when they raise taxes it's like
well then we'll just come up with more
taxes and we'll fix it well let's see
what happens on uh next Monday is when
they're gonna be uh I guess the judge
will issue a ruling but then eight days
from now 21st and 22nd is the trial date
if it makes it that far should be very
interesting let's jump to this story
from timcast.com
printful Cuts ties with gays against
groomers group seeks legal action
claiming defamation quote we are looking
into all of our options with our
attorney Ron Coleman and intend to
pursue legal action you ready for this
one all right gaze against groomers this
is an organization of lgbtq people who
oppose groomers anyone of any background
who targets children to groom them all
right here's the best part
printful on Sunday who produced
merchandise for the organization
suspended business with gays against
groomers to quote mitigate the risk of
being affiliated with an organization
that doesn't represent our company
values we do our best to remain neutral
and respect freedom of speech yet we
draw the line of content that foments
hatred towards any person or group reads
an email let me break that down for you
printful is explicitly saying on the
issue of pedophilia they are neutral and
don't want to be associated with an
organization that would disparage
pedophiles oops hey hey didn't Michael
Jordan say that groomers buy sneakers
too right
am I getting that wrong I
I'm tying the market on on the groomer
Market it's a pretty big Market out
there especially with Balenciaga and
their marketing campaign especially with
the FBI and you know protecting Epstein
for over 30 years ditching the victims
to the side I mean hey this is a
business trying to make money here and
let's call us you know a spade a spade
here they they want groomer money and
they want to support uh well you set it
right there hold on a minute you know
imagine you make t-shirts right and you
got these really wealthy individuals
like Epstein and his clients you don't
want to lose those people you know so
printful is upset that yikes
but look
we keep giving the benefit of the doubt
whenever stories like this happen and
we're like oh they probably just assume
gaze against groomer is anti-lgbtq or
something and I'm like no no you can't
do that here
the organization is called gays against
groomers it's literally like people who
are lgbtq being like pedophiles are bad
and they're like we're gonna you're
inciting hatred against them so we're
gonna be neutral on this one okay okay
principal like Luke said go hang out
with Balenciaga see how that's doing see
how see how it's working out for them I
mean they only got a yay supporting
Balenciaga I don't know anyone else is
supporting them uh seriously
and he made statements in favor of them
yeah recently but other than that I mean
I I think it's pretty clear that a lot
of people weren't happy with uh the way
that they handled their marketing and I
think this is pretty obvious I mean it
the organization's name is gays against
groomers and and you're you're getting
rid of their ability to sell merchandise
because you don't agree with them their
main thing that they do is that they're
pushing against groomers against people
who hurt children you're saying we don't
like that yeah we're we're neutral on
that issue they try to pretend like it's
not a real thing it is absolutely a real
thing and you've seen them try to change
the language and the narrative in
Academia right I'm sure you've heard of
the acronym NOW they use minor yes Maps
right so Oh that's oh so so there's
another statement they said we suspended
gays against groomers because the
underlying homophobic and transphobic
misinformation spread by this
organization does not align with our
values of respect and inclusion let us
be clear that we do not condone child
abuse or The Grooming of minors we uh we
will not work with an organization that
spreads harmful accusations against the
lgbtq plus Community under the guise of
protecting children you see what they're
doing even if you are lgbtq and you
explicitly are just like hey it's the
grooming of a problem with they accuse
you of being homophobic and transphobic
it's like yo they're literally gay
so let me show you something funny
Media Matters put out this uh thing uh
it's the retweets it mentions Media
Matters yeah right wing figures
anti-lgbtq tweets and accounts before
and after musk acquired Twitter yeah I'm
number one you can see Tim pool right up
top I have uh 20 261 retweets that
mention groomer
3153 uh mentions of the word groomer
what they don't tell you in this is that
the Tweets in question are me saying
quote
groomer does not refer to lgbtq people
so I have like three tweets that got
like tens of thousands of retweets or
whatever specifically saying that they
then take it and call that anti-lgbtq
because they're lying and manipulating
and for some reason I just don't know
why Media Matters really wants people to
believe that that lgbtq people are
pedophiles now I don't know why they
would do that but let me let me let me
give you a really good example Blair
white is on the list Blair white
responded with like the clownery of me
being on this list Blair white is trans
this is absolutely insane and gaze
against groomers is number three
I just want to um
send my condolences to jack besobic for
being number two sorry Jack there's a
new game in town that's the first loser
right second place yeah that's right
jack second place is the first loser
this is but it's ridiculous
I mean the whole thing is ridiculous
that it it's literally considering the
fact that it's gays against groomers the
the they're essentially saying that
it's not about LGBT it's about the left
and we're using LGBT people uh as as a a
way to to push forward our leftist
agenda not specifically the things that
that the LGBT uh LGBT people want
because gays against rumors are
obviously LGBT and have a different
political perspective it's just that the
left is it has taken the taken on the
mantle of LGBT and anything that the
LGBT Lobby does is uh always the last
it's always associated with the left or
with the left ones you know uh I love
simulism Elon Musk was talking about
simulation theory on stage I guess when
he was getting booed or something and
I'll tell you why because because I I
kind of have to just believe I'm half
kidding by the way that when I come out
and every statement I've given on this
every video I've done explicitly is
about how groomer does not mean lgbtq
but they keep saying it does they have
to just be a bunch of like mobs
non-player characters roaming around
randomly on the hillside controlled by
no one because like I don't know how
we're at the point where I go oh the
word groomer doesn't in any way refer to
lgbtq people they just immediately go
why are you calling gay people
pedophiles and I'm like well I literally
just said the opposite what are you
talking about that's where we're at
right now so it's look in all reality
it's a cult but it's hard for me to
believe that even an occult they can
hear you say you know the sky is blue
and then they go the sky is not green
and I didn't say it was where are you
getting these ideas from that that's
where we're at right now how you solve
for that I have no idea maybe it's not
even solvable
I'm sure they've gone out and pulled it
and realized that we're on the right
side of it
and you know they're like oh we got to
stop this I mean you know
to me it's just you know you go back to
when Trump's saying fake news fake media
back 2016-15 and they were like this is
made up no we're very very on and it
turns out of course yes there is fake
news that is a real thing
are you familiar with the name Chris
saliza he got fired from CNN yeah he has
an immortal tweet a tweet that was
immortalized he one time tweeted I'm
gonna say again for the thousandth time
or whatever the the media doesn't pick a
side and it has been I I have gotten a
whole lot of mileage out of that bad boy
let me tell you I got that saved in my
phone yeah and that thing is has allowed
me to perform some fun dunks but uh it's
true like the media narrative is
unquestionably a leftist narrative
there's no more room for denying it or
arguing it the Overton window of
acceptable argument or acceptable debate
has been set by the left and anyone that
steps outside of it is looked at as you
know Untouchable and the goal of the
left is a whole cultural revolution in
the United States like are you familiar
with James Lindsay so I'm I'm totally
like I'm right on the same page with
that guy James Lindsay Chris rufo those
guys really have their I think they have
their finger right on the pulse of of
the real heart of the problem in the
heart of the problem is that schools
have been infiltrated by left-leaning
people that have an ideology that they
are using in education and it's the
schools of education so it's not just
your colleges your where kids are going
it's the schools that teach teachers so
these teachers that are coming out of
the schools of Education are
indoctrinated into an ideology that they
cannot even see they are unaware that
they are indoctrinated in it they are
completely unaware that they have been
taken and given a framework to look at
the world
that is like putting on racism colored
glasses or sexism colored glasses
essentially their oppression colored
glasses and all they see in the whole
world is oppression and when you teach
kids through a lens of Oppression you
you psychologically damage them because
young people should not be shown the
world as a place that is full of
Oppression even if that's the case that
you can say look there's all kinds of
different ways that people are oppressed
you don't tell seven-year-olds because
that's emotionally damages them and they
become they they lose they they get
depressed and there's all kinds of
horrible things and you're seeing in in
the the levels of depression in young
people nowadays you've got so many
people on ssris it's because of the way
that people that kids are taught in
schools and it's it's it's because of a
left-leaning I'll give you a great
example today today I was at a high
school given an award to a teacher that
actually cared uh who's doing a great
job in her school school and I walk into
the school before I get in I walk
through the parking lot and
not really any bumper stickers on the
cars except for two of them and two of
those cars parked right next to each
other both had Bernie Sanders stickers
you know these kind of real left-wing
slogans on it and it's like seriously
what were the slogans ah I can't
remember how the left wing because some
left-wing slogans are slogans like you
know everybody deserves health care and
then there are other left-wing slogans
like liberals get the bullet too yeah
yeah
it wasn't that left wing but it was you
know you got Bernie on there and then
just this last week last week I had I
think they're all that left wing at the
end of the day though is my prize my
point because it's a religion at the end
of the day so I had a uh concerned group
of parents came to me uh Wood County
West Virginia that's out in Parkersburg
and they said and this is a very
conservative County they said you won't
believe what our children have access to
they showed me this material all the
children yeah and so something actually
very very similar to this so these
points are probably gender actually is
that book yes I think actually look
inside it's it's got the pictures that's
it that's the one that's the book and
that's the book that they have access to
and these parents their children because
we were living in covid and all that
people got iPads and all that and that's
how they were accessing books and it's
on the accessible reading list through
the library for elementary school
children elementary school children have
access to this I mean what in the hell
is going on here I tell you and this is
just and this is Wood County West
Virginia Which tells you it's probably
happening at all I mean all over the
state but it's just absolutely shocking
stuff Tim did you have something you
wanted to say or did I just want to uh
I'm pretty sure that YouTube age
restricted the project Veritas video
from the Chicago teacher which is kind
of ironic since YouTube doesn't think
it's it's okay for small children to
watch when it literally happens to small
children which is absolutely
mind-boggling well it's like when the
when the parents came in and said I'm
going to read you from this book start
reading stuff and then they're like hey
hey you can't say that here order order
if you keep talking we'll kick you out
and they're like what you made my kids
read this book yeah the whole point of
that is because it's as much as there
are people that are worried about the
LGBT issues the point the LGBT issues in
that are really a tertiary topic the
point is to have is to make
revolutionaries to make kids that are
unhappy with the way Society is because
it's the marxists call it cultural
hegemony right it's the society remakes
the society so when you have kids that
go to school that learn how to be good
Americans they go and they come out of
school and they go into jobs and they
become good Americans and they make more
kids that go to schools that learn how
to be good Americans what the left wants
to do is get into the schools and stop
making stop having those kids that go in
come out as good Americans they want at
least a portion of them to come out as
radical leftist revolutionaries and if
you get a portion of them to come out
like that all you have to do is get you
know whatever a third or ten percent or
twenty percent of the population to be
really really upset and that can uproot
the whole civil realization and that's
the goal the goal is a revolution and
anyone that tells you anything different
is lying to you yeah now I don't know if
this is in this book or not but part of
the material that brought it's like two
young guys and here's how you satisfy
your partner and I mean literally yeah
but that just shows Discord yeah like I
said what's going on in there the sexual
stuff that's tertiary yeah that's right
the point is the Discord the point is
the fact that they're revolutionary the
point is they don't fall into categories
that you would consider normal they that
they're they're not heading they're not
hegemonic categories they become
revolutionary there somehow uh they're
somehow subversive or whatever and if
you can subvert the whole society or if
you convert subvert a portion of the
society to the point that they will
ferment a revolution then you can uproot
capitalism right you can get rid of
capitalism you can get rid of what they
would what they would call hierarchies
that are uh uh um that are unfair
oppressive hierarchies and and the whole
intent is to throw the whole system over
and destroy it all because they think
that the system is illegitimate they
think capitalism they think that owning
property they think that that the reason
that they're against free speech is
because they don't believe that there is
Free Speech they believe that you're
only trying to use speech as a way to
exercise power right well look and I do
know people in West Virginia listen to
this we're fixing this next month in the
legislature so just hang tight
I hope you're right because this is
James Lindsay like I said I I I'm I
think he's on on the right track and if
he is right a cultural revolution in the
United States like the one that happened
in China you know it's going on right
now and kids are attacking their parents
and you see you know you've got videos
of kids screaming on college campuses
screaming at the teachers that's the
same thing that happened in China you
see that uh woman who was at her dad's
funeral or whatever yes attacking him
horrifying but yes and it's the exact
opposite of honor thy father and thy
mother 100 yeah well I mean look in West
Virginia I run what's called The Hope
Scholarship so that's an educational
savings account and that has allowed
kids to take their and their parents
their version of taxpayer dollars and
use it uh outside of the public school
system it's educational freedom in West
Virginia we also allow families to use
that for uh homeschoolers so
homeschoolers can also take look it's
their tax dollars let them use it and
educate their children how they want to
and that is is a way that we're able to
get some of our kids here in the near
future away from this stuff and get back
control homeschooling is key it's very
important and millions of Americans are
starting to do this you're right about
homeschooling I hate to throw water on
what you were saying but the the video
that Veritas just put up that's a
private school yeah yeah well I mean but
this is why we have homeschool as a part
of it home school is important
homeschool because then they're yeah and
we have a huge homeschool population in
West Virginia and it was very
controversial particularly with the
teachers unions including homeschool
students in this but it is part of it we
also have a legislation that's under my
purview also so we got micro pods uh we
have our learning pods pardon me and so
where you can get groups of homeschool
kids come together and use what's called
The Hope Scholarship their tax dollars
to be able to educate themselves free of
all of this and just parents coming
together and what used to happen in this
country in a very traditional manner uh
you know trying to get back to those
things I mean the the cultural left
constantly wants to like have a
revolution every five years of what is a
norm in this country when to me you know
a lot of people are like well I'm a
conservative it's like what are we if
you're conservative what are you trying
to conserve like there was a point
someone dropped on the show a while ago
that the the fact that our lives are
dramatically different from our
grandparents is unique to this time
period yeah for all of human history
your you and your grandparents had
basically the exact same kind of life it
was uh it was population growth was was
stagnant your grandfather farmed you
farmed your grandfather was a blacksmith
you blacksmith you very much live the
same life now with rapid the rapid
advancement of technology and Energy
Technologies our lives are completely
different and culturally though Tim
there there's a thing it's called
transmission right and happens through
generational things your parents have
taught you their parents taught them and
there's transmission of those Norms
values things like that that each family
has different Norms cultures and values
that they hold dear that's all been
blown up yeah right I mean to your point
this has all been destroyed and it gets
leveled out like every five years and it
gets lower and lower and lower the level
that we're at yeah to continue the
conversation about schooling I I think
there's a reason David Rockefeller
influenced our modern education system
which is really an indoctrination system
and now that he's no longer here uh with
us other individuals have kind of taken
his mantle and are also influencing
education those individuals are
individuals like Bill Gates Mark
Zuckerberg that have spent hundreds of
millions of dollars on new experimental
education that has lowered reading
levels made students uh less intelligent
as they're promoting more woke doctrines
and Equity these are literally the
policies that are being influenced right
now by a lot of very powerful
individuals setting up this education
system which is not really educating
people at all just indoctrinated them
into the woke cult yeah let me and if
you sorry just real quick you look at
those National test scores they are
freaking abysmal they are awful I mean
it cannot get any worse well I guess it
could get worse but this is the lowest
it's been in decades it is awful and
that is I do want to point this out if I
am elected to congress if I get in I'm
going to be pushing for national school
choice just like we have in West
Virginia give people back control of
their tax dollars to be able to educate
their families home school or otherwise
somebody said to me the other day
wouldn't that destroy the Department of
Education I said yes exactly that's well
that's yeah you should like say Thomas
Massey I am fully for the abolition of
like
cabinet level bureaucracies get rid of
the Department of Education you look at
it since Jimmy Carter put it in it's
just gotten worse and worse and worse
preach reach let's let's jump to this
story we have this from CNN U.S
lawmakers introduced Bill to ban Tick
Tock they say Senator Marco Rubio the
top Republic on the Senate intelligence
committee and a bipartisan pair of
congressmen in the house reflects the
latest escalation by U.S policymakers
against the Chinese owned short form
video app Tick Tock has faced doubts
about its ability to safeguard U.S user
data from the Chinese government I'm
pretty sure it just sends your data to
the Chinese government doesn't it yeah
yes absolutely and I mean do you think
it should be banned I do think it should
be banned and you've seen this with
Huawei huawei's made entrance into a lot
of developed countries it's been proven
time and time again that they are spying
on them they're collecting data this is
exactly what Tick Tock is doing we need
to be very clear that China is our
greatest adversary in the world we do
know that right and I think we need to
be acting as such
what should we do about Tick Tock ban it
get rid of it
well essentially they're doing with the
DHS and NSA are doing here domestically
inside of the United States I I think
the the bigger answer would be to make
people aware that everything they do
online isn't private everything is being
collected there's an entire data centers
that the United States is financing
through your tax dollars that literally
creates uh you know personality traits
about who you are what you're going to
be doing
um and Zuckerberg knows when you poop
exactly and but that's the lowest level
of it but it's not just about that it's
about how Tick Tock is feeding all this
woke stuff so we're talking about what's
going on in schools Tick Tock is a huge
component of crushing the brains of
young people in this country yes exactly
look at you know Chinese Tick Tock
versus U.S Tick Tock right right I mean
it's it's incredibly different the type
of algorithm that's being pushed here in
the United States it's trying to be
culturally destructive it's trying to be
divisive uh I think it is a huge problem
I do
tax the E thoughts yeah
that's the crazy thing too that we've
talked about with like uh Instagram
somebody was mentioning how they they
searched first for I can't remember what
they're talking about you search for
anything on Instagram and it's going to
be some kind of sexualized content with
women and like
rule 34. no but I I guess but like not
not creating porn but like
you will just search for you know action
sports or something and then they will
find a way to feed or I should say young
women are finding a way to make content
seem sexual because it gets them clicks
the algorithm is generating this then
you have only fans that's the direction
we're going all of these things are just
components and it all Fallen apart yes
yeah I mean absolutely it goes back to
that generational transmission too I
mean if we were transmitting values
Norms I mean generationally to
Millennials and everybody else now I
mean would they be doing those things
you know I I'm not exactly sure now I
mean we're like in a society of me me me
me and and that's kind of what drives
all of this
it's crazy man I'm reading some of these
stories there's like some woman accused
of murder and she's like she's gonna pay
her bail with only fans money and I'm
like that's just so crazy these stories
about women who are like millionaires
now they figured it out just get naked
on the internet and there's money
waiting but it doesn't work for
everybody ladies secure your bag all
right that being said it is probably not
a good idea to have an only fans
think about think about where we end up
in 10 years a woman who is 26 is making
a bunch of money and only fans
not all of them uh some of them you know
average I think the average is actually
pretty low yeah like the average is bad
it's like right not even like 70 bucks I
think but that's because yeah but that's
be that's like most people aren't going
to make money but of the win who do what
happens in 10 years they're 36. I have
really really bad opinions about this
and I'm it's it's making me nervous well
now you got to tell everybody well
because it's it's a it's it's a young
it's a Young Person's game and there are
so many young ladies that are told that
because they're that mistake being young
for being pretty and then they're
fighting in this slew of young people
right young women where they're just
young they're not really particularly
pretty it's you know it's it's like they
they get this idea that oh because the
Five Guys that keep hitting on me over
at the at the bar keep hitting on me and
won't go away I must be hot then they
get on only fans and then next thing you
know there's only fan or only girls on
only fans posting their L's posting
these comments from these these horribly
broken women that just you know thought
oh I'm pretty and I'm gonna get on the
internet I'm gonna make a lot of money
because guys think I'm pretty and then
the internet treats them like like
horrible horrible horrible you know but
it's rough it's not it's not okay the
point I want to make is you get a woman
let's say she's attractive in 26. 10
years ago now she's 36. a lot of the
guys have either paired up or are no
longer interested because they want a 26
year old but she's still probably doing
well and attractive woman in a 30 is
going to do all right 46. now what
happens to a woman who has no
discernible skills because she spent a
couple decades doing only fans now she's
in her late 40s what does she do does
she open like an only Fan's Network to
to court young talent and manage their
accounts for them or something don't
need to it's all automated through the
system does only well let's assuming
only fans last that long or something
like this happens these women will
eventually get too old to be able to do
this and make money and then what then
they go to the state and they say the
it's the government's fault they should
pay me yeah and not even without the AI
and Anime stuff that's coming our way oh
it's going to totally destroy Society in
many different ways but I I just looked
it up the average only fans Creator
earns about a hundred eighty to 150 a
month according to the best estimates
out there like that is can you imagine
thinking that you're a pretty young girl
at 20 years old right not and like the
only experience you've had is in town
everyone has treated you like you're the
hottest girl around because there's 30
girls that are young and pretty and
you're the hottest of the 30 but put you
in like you know on the internet and
then you're competing with like
beautiful women from all over the world
and then you get treated like crap
because you're not as pretty as the
prettiest and it just destroys your
[ __ ] your self-esteem it's it's just
I'm not saying that there aren't that
women shouldn't do it I'm not the guy
that's going to judge people that do
that like that's not what I'm saying but
it's not as easy as people think it's
like like I'm a musician and I'm in a
band and the chances of me at actually
succeeding for as long as I have it is
no nobody is is as lucky as I am like it
never happens the fact that I've been
doing this for 20 years as a
professional musician that wasn't even
in the cards I didn't think I'm gonna
start a band and I'm going to be
successful I thought I'm gonna start a
band and play on the weekends and work a
day job for the rest of my life right
that's what I expected and thankfully it
didn't work out that way and I'm super
fortunate but like your average person
your average young girl that starts and
only fans account thinking that she's
gonna you know she's gonna get beat up
emotionally and it's gonna it's gonna
hurt and it's just and they can never
take it back yeah and content will
always be on the internet people will
take pictures on their phones with
another phone or something like that and
you can never take it back and it's
going to come up in job interviews for
the rest of your life I mean it's just
you know like you're saying I mean the
odds of becoming a millionaire at this I
mean are so minimal but secondarily I
mean do you want to be in your 50s and
60s and trying to cling to relevance and
trying to still live that lifestyle it's
just that's a sad Road you know I I
don't I don't want to sound like I'm
coming off judging anybody at all you
know because I understand that there are
problems later in life that come along
with it and stuff but at the I really
think that the most of the damage
happens to young people because of the
because of the expectation and then we
reality hits them because by the time
you're 40 if you've been living that
life you know what's coming you know
it's like if you've been living that
life you're 36 you're you know you're
like yeah man clock is ticking and these
things ain't up here anymore they're
down here or whatever you know it's like
that it's not like you're high that
that's a secret you know well another
aspect is that the market has become so
competitive it's not so you know I I
think talking to to some of the women
out there they have this notion that oh
I could just post whatever picture and
I'll get millions of dollars it doesn't
work that way a lot of the the biggest
earners work extremely hard uh on their
content on messaging people they have PR
teams they have they have entire
marketing teams that work with them it's
not just as as some people think like
because again on average 150 a month
there's that uh that that old saying
every woman has boobs yeah every woman
has boobs hey they gave you that warning
you know but it's not true actually I
think the average amount of boobs is is
less than two the average the average
amount of Limbs is less than two one
point 1.89 boobs per per woman it is
because like you get any individual
who's had like an amputation or a
mastectomy and then brings the whole
average down but my point is like Lucas
said there's a lot of a lot of women who
think they're going to be successful at
this not realizing that there's
100 plus million American women you know
you're competing with all of the ones
willing to do it which is a lot and so
that's like massive Supply with with
like demand can only get as high as
there are dudes but Supply is is and if
you're coming in cold like you've never
done any kind of Social Media stuff they
don't realize that like content is dry
is the driver you have to keep feeding
that content machine so that means you
gotta post pictures every day and you
gotta interact with the fans that are
paying you in blah blah blah it's like
and it's not stop work yeah it's like
more than uh nine to five I can't post
on my Instagram page enough to feel like
I am getting the most out of my
Instagram page yeah I mean if it sounds
too good to be true it's because it is
yeah so I mean it's it's a lot of work
it's hard you know and it's just it
sounds like it's oh look this person
makes millions but yeah that person is
probably not just like waking up taking
a picture and then going about there
yeah I mean like in your business that's
being like Oh somebody sings and they
make money I'll start singing yeah it's
is not how it works that's what people
think that is how they think what you
know the song Money for Nothing yeah
yeah that ain't working that's the way
you do it the guitar on the MTV yeah
that's a good song wasn't it like the
the band was uh they're like a Best Buy
or something they overheard some guy say
that or something like that I mean that
wouldn't surprise me I I don't know the
story but urban legend but like I heard
a story that they were they were at like
a furniture store and they overheard two
guys watching one of their music videos
are watching music and like watching MTV
or something and then they were like
that ain't working you know that that's
the job we should get and it's just like
yeah it's probably more work it's it's
it's it's substantially more work people
think that uh like YouTube for instance
they're like man I really want to do
that and I'm like yeah it's like endless
work Mark wrote it after overhearing a
delivery man in New York Department
Store complained about their jobs while
watching MTV he wrote the song in the
store sitting in a kitchen display they
had set up there you go any of the
lyrics were things they actually said
that ain't working that's the way you
play the guitar on the MTV money for
nothing and the chicks for free for
nothing then chicks for free and then a
lot of these musicians end up doing
drugs becoming extremely depressed they
hate their lives and uh it's funny when
you hear about these big bands that
break up and I remember growing up you'd
hear about a band that broke up or
whatever and then people would be like
why would they break up they were
successful and it's like yeah and the
other ones that don't do a bunch of
heroin right it must not be all that
great All That Remains is had you know
we had we have had one person pass away
a couple years back uh one guy I was an
alcoholic or Eminem I don't drink
anymore uh you know so that kind of
light like the the lifestyle is real
we've gone through more drummers
probably gone through as many drummers
as uh as spinal tap I think like seven
or eight we go through drummers like mad
uh it's hard to play blast beats and
double bass man that's hard wait until
you find out about child celebrities and
the people that Disney brings up oh God
I don't want to I don't want him
it's crazy man I I talked to uh Eliza
blue like she's on Twitter and stuff for
mutuals and stuff and hearing that poor
woman like she is so damn strong and the
work that she has done is really really
really great and hearing the the you
know the stories that she's she's
related it's I don't I don't I don't
envy that poor poor soul she is uh she's
done great work but man she is she has
paid you know let's go to super chats if
you haven't already would you kindly
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share the share with your
friends and become a member at
timcast.com so type that in timcast.com
Click join us become a member and we
will have on the front page in the left
side is a members only uncensored show
that goes up Monday through Thursday at
11 PM we got one for you tonight but
let's read your super chats right now so
smash that like button we got Dapper
mcstash he says Tim and Ian guys the
fusion facility in California got
another sustained ignition with an
energy gain factor of almost 1.5 check
the New York Times I heard that that is
big yup so I think they were saying
something like the amount of fuel
required for Fusion is like a kilogram
compared to Modern energy output of
comparable and a comparable energy
output would be like 10 000 tons of fuel
so uh this is big news yeah because
China is actually pretty Advanced on
that aren't they I mean I don't know
yeah I saw an article a little while
back that I mean they're they're making
strides but the other thing too I don't
think people are talking about and I I
would need to ask an expert they're
they're fusing hydrogen into helium so
this does this mean we can effectively
have a byproduct of manufactured helium
maybe yeah and helium is finite on this
planet and we're worried about running
out so maybe that's a solution all right
Kevin Pilgrim says Phil again how the
hell did I get so lucky let's go yeah
yeah he's here he was chilling we were
like yeah just come on the show he's
like all right
let's grab some more news
ruler of the star of star says Phil is
back for the last time with a darkened
heart he has to stand up for his Victory
lap hold on this probably won't end for
at least two weeks or are we asking too
much how many did you get in there's
like 10 song these like 10 song titles
in there I think I think good job I
think a bunch of people tried playing a
game of cramming as many titles as
possible how many other remains titles
can be put into the sentence yeah
where are we at a lot of people just
saying yeah welcome back that's great
thank you guys there will be a follow at
Phil that remains on the Twitter machine
there you go Reaper's son says Tim can
you bring Matt Bender back on or at
least call him out on Twitter for the
way his his twisting the Twitter files
information and lying to people I mean
that just sounds like the left I guess
it sounds like Matt binder yeah I mean
hey props for coming on the show you
know he did when he came on I've said
this on Twitter when he came on I I was
watching the show and it was
so frustrating to watch him because I'm
just like this guy is twisting
everything he's so full of crap and I
you know I mean I I appreciate the fact
that he came on obviously because you
know it's good to have people that
disagree and stuff but it's really
really frustrating for some to hear
someone that is so intent on controlling
the narrative we are gonna have one heck
of a show soon with uh I'm not gonna say
say who but we actually were able to
book a couple different very very
prominent leftists at the same time
so this is wild this is going to be fun
I'm not gonna I want to say who it is
but uh
I don't know if leftist is the right
word but you know liberal Democrat type
personalities so it should be
interesting Matt Bender kind of style
but we'll see we'll see communists
I don't know I don't know I don't know I
I think I don't know who it is let's
let's uh we'll just we'll just read I I
don't like saying guess in advance in
case they cancel and people get
disappointed or whatever but uh look I
gotta tell you we invite leftists and
liberals come on and they just ignore it
they they talk smack online and then I
reply with I'd love for you to say that
on my show to all of my viewers and
they're like I ain't going to film it's
like okay don't you want to tell people
what you think about me no they're like
no he had the black Nazi on
they just want to tell their people what
they think all right David door says Tim
I'm so sorry to hear about Mr bocus's
declining health I lost a cat to
lymphoma a few years ago after endless
treatments radiation and chemo it's
heartbreaking I just wanted you to know
I feel it I really do appreciate it
David door I can give you guys an update
he's home
um I haven't seen him yet because he
came home while we were starting the
show he's on medication but the doctor
referred to as palliative or hospice
care unfortunately Mr bocus either has
developmental organ issues or genetic
issues but I think it's probably
developmental because he he was born in
the streets probably ate garbage you
know garbage in bad organ development
he's got undeveloped kidneys which made
him susceptible to to chronic kidney
disease which happens in cats and
unfortunately because of his heart Pro
his genetic heart defects he is not a
good candidate for a kidney transplant
if we were going to even try and get one
nor can you receive dialysis if we were
going to consider getting it for him
which maybe it's just really expensive
so uh what they said was they hope he
makes it to Christmas and that's just
crazy because like six months ago we did
a photo shoot and we got a picture of
him on the website so if you if you go
to timcast.com
when you click join us you'll see a
talent roster of just various
personalities who who work here and
bocus is front and center Roberto Jr is
the bottom right he's a rooster that we
raised and uh bocus looks very plump and
healthy and that was like six months ago
so it just hit
um we were worried that it was something
we did but they told us they're like no
no you know they they like three
different doctors were like with a
cardiologist internal medicine as well
as the ER doctor and they were like
looking at him and looking at everything
it seems like it was just something that
was going to start happening his kidneys
eventually we're going to start getting
weaker and then it's a rapid progression
and it's a it's just very very
unfortunate but we're gonna we're you
know we're gonna bring him out the
Christmas party and uh I I have formally
made it a job requirement for timcast
employees to inform Mr Beau because that
they love him so uh it's been formally
announced I'm kidding by the way but I
jokingly did say that everybody you
gotta tell bocus you'll love them
because he may they said they hope he
makes it to Christmas so we're going to
be giving him hormones for his blood
count we're going to be giving him IV
fluids
they said maybe maybe he'll make it a
couple months and if he does they'll
want to see him again and see how he's
doing they said he's voracious and
they're actually surprised considering
his levels how he's behaving as if
nothing's wrong and that's actually the
problem we didn't know anything was
wrong with him because he's a tough
little sob and he acted like there were
no problems so we saw no symptoms uh he
got a little thin and we brought him the
vet vet was like well you know just get
him a better food and they didn't even
the vet didn't even think to check for
kidney failure until he started blacking
out started dropping to the floor and
then we were like okay and that was on
Friday we rushed into the ER and they
were like yo he's like on the verge of
death and we were like what little
homeboy was putting up a tough fight and
pretending like no problem was happening
so with the medicine you know we'll see
but I do appreciate it we're gonna try
and figure out our to the best of our
abilities how to immortalize Mr bocus I
think we'll have him choose an heir so
we wanted we want to rescue another cat
and then we'll have him you know
whichever one he gets along with me a
kitten and then maybe if we get a kitten
soon he can teach you know the kitten
the the business you know how to be a
good uh uh uh you know c-suite
personality for the company and then
when he invariably passes unfortunately
then we'll have uh bocus too
but uh it is what it is man you know we
will mourn for Mr bocus get him cremated
and put a uh a little bit of Mr bocus
and a necklace around your Viking
funeral ah there you go yeah I think
bocus gets a viking funeral
a little boat with a little flaming
arrow and we'll well you got the river
just right over here that's right yeah
perfect Viking funeral for Mr bocus
Perfect I don't know if that's illegal
but you know we'll look into it it's
better to ask uh better to ask
forgiveness rather than permission yeah
yeah but I don't know if like so we're
in an Adventure Center area where
there's tons of people I don't know I've
seen a cat on fire is something that it
sounds Adventures to me I don't know
about anyone else that sounds like an
adventure that I'd be interested in
think of it if they understood what was
happening there before there's the other
thing we can do where we can set up a
pyre you know how they do it yeah yeah
funeral pyre and like we'll make we'll
do something really great who's gonna
shoot the bow
like you I don't know I don't want to
shoot it you might want to do a crossbow
because then you definitely yeah yeah
they're very accurate crossbow we I've
we got a bunch of bows and uh I'm not
gonna pretend like I'm actually good or
anything but accurate enough to where
I'm not super worried about it all right
yeah well but we'll do a funeral pyre we
won't do uh uh a boat I like the boat
idea I mean he deserves a boat I think
if he's out in the water and you and you
shoot a flaming arrow I mean you are
shooting into the water yeah yeah that's
fine you come over to the West Virginia
people fish people fish with bows and
arrows all the time it's totally fine
come to West Virginia side I know the
guy that Rose uh owns River Riders
sure he'd let you do it there you go
figure out a viking funeral for Mr Bogus
yeah we could maybe find somebody who's
like an expert Archer to do the official
you know or everyone has a yeah just
everybody takes a shot my arrows will
blot out the sun yeah but I also think
uh uh uh you know of getting a little
bust made of of Mr bocus someone someone
someone sent us a bust of me and it's
funny because like downstairs on the
table on the table under the TV is a
bronze like bust of my head and it's
very strange for me that ex that it
exists because that we made fun of Dr
fauci for having a painting of himself
and then I think it was uh maybe it was
Mike cernovich who was like his daughter
probably painted that for him and I was
like oh that's a good point and then I
walk downstairs and I'm like there's a
statue of my head right in my own house
that's awful like but somebody made it
and it was a gift and so I really
appreciate they did that but I'm like I
get it I get it you know I'll lay off
fouchie for the painting thing and call
him out for the lying thing right let's
read some more Super chats James Jarvis
says lady at Subway today got angry with
all male crew taking a while looked at
me quote no offense the problem is there
aren't any women I told her that's
offensive and she's sexist I said no
offense what if I said inverse nada
well there you go yeah
uh I I don't want to say this word
because I don't know if it's offensive
so I'll search first oh no ruin Nick it
just means redneck
why would you just call me zeph bro come
on Serge speaks Africa uh Africans like
a like a ruining donkey
[Laughter]
Tina Collett says Tim be real would you
rather trust a genzir or a Jen Jones
late Boomers early gen xers that's the
first ever heard Jen Jones for that Jen
Jones uh probably Jim Jones
I don't know I probably not a genzir
yeah I mean there's a handful that I
know that are great you know we've had a
few on the show we have some working
here but like early gen xers late
Boomers
I think they're all right they made Star
Trek yeah yeah the Next Generation yeah
yeah there you go Phil you're you're a
gen xerx there you go Gen X good people
Millennials I kind of feel like gen xers
have a tendency to be okay boomers are a
mixed bag and Millennials are like
leaning towards being really awful gen Z
I'm not so sure that they might be a
mixed bag as well
maybe we'll see
I don't know it's going to be
interesting in 10 in eight years when 10
year olds today are voting and you know
you're going to be talking to some
imagine this it's going to be 20 32.
I'm going to be in my in my late 40s and
we're going to have a 25 year old highly
influential you know personality in
politics and I'm going to say something
about you know look I know Biden is uh
is is running for president for the 87th
time you know he's a hundred and you
know and they're going to be and then
I'm gonna say but don't you remember
back in 2026 when he was doing the I
don't know I was I was a little kid I
don't remember and you'd be like oh yeah
well when we had vosh on the show and we
talked about the the Obama
Administration he was like oh I was a
kid back then I don't know anything
about that and I was like oh man Jesus
but remarkable a 20 a 22 year old
leftist influencer does not know about
the Obama era yeah if they were 10 years
old or 12 years old or 10. I don't know
anything about the Obama era but he's
going to tell you it's all about marks
that's right that's right truth oh man
dalamar says Phil do not bring a
spotlight on Gen X we are quietly taking
all the cookies before anyone notices
ligamouth again says what the Flink are
you gabbing at Jack I ain't old who else
can provide better calf Karen chuna
shabbata pressure Corn Pop is the old
Sun [ __ ] in the room but you flurge and
uh the thing let's do push-ups and
larger for better if you ask me squisely
Carter vend unprepped wow I I think that
is probably the most accurate but I can
quote anyone has ever produced listen
here Jack we're gonna better calf care
people try to decipher what true in and
out of Shabbat of pressure was
so when he said uh remember that one
yeah he was trying to say I was in the
foothills of again
as a federal visit I was in the
foothills of Afghanistan and that's how
it comes out right so we get it what is
true true
International
something pressure cooperation could be
cooperation depressed true International
cooperation under pressure
what's that
I don't know
it's almost like have you seen that you
ever saw that movie uh Pootie Tang oh
yeah oh yeah yeah yeah yeah you remember
Pootie Tang yeah that's a Louis CK movie
yeah uh Chris Rock Yeah Yeah Chris Rock
did it he's like uh Sanyo pity on the
Run account yeah but but didn't Louis CK
direct it I think he did yeah no I think
you're right yeah yeah yeah it's funny
also he says Gen X were the last
independent generation but they vowed to
raise their kids differently and the Le
and the leftists of us started the
participation trophies while we were
working with our fingers to we're
working our fingers to the Bone
I think it was Boomers who did the
participation trophies and it was a
millennial so there's like an in-between
phase I mean I mean the whole thing is
waves so it's like you can be you can be
in between Gen X and well I know you
could be the cusp of millennial or
whatever but uh you know I was raised by
middle tier Boomers and my everything I
knew growing up was all the
participation trophy stuff that Gen X at
the time were in their late teens and
early 20s and they were not doing that
stuff no they were they were drinking uh
Pepsi I think that's what it was right I
I was a code kid generation next
I mean the the ad was generation next
for Pepsi but yeah Love Pepsi I know
because the commercials told me
let's see what we got
Dan on S says Gen X has been taking care
of ourselves since we were six and y'all
are surprised we don't have we don't D
we don't to deal with everyone else's
crap you don't want to deal yeah I'm not
surprised latchkey kids
yep
where are we at
Mike bouvat says Joe Biden equals post
Turtle when you're driving down a
country road you come across a fence
post with a turtle balanced on top
that's a post turtle
is that where you're asking yourself how
did it get there I think so yeah I think
I'm not sure but so people don't know is
that turtles will stack
Turtles like climbing on top of each
other and then spreading their legs out
to dry off and so what happens is the
turtles will go up to the fences and
stack on top of each other and then
eventually one is up on top and then the
others will leave and you get a turtle
up top or they fall over
so there was this old song 10 years ago
uh about it's about building a turtle
fence so it was a Shmo Yoho on YouTube
took this Congressional testimony about
building a turtle fence and then did an
auto-tune version of it it's actually
really funny the turtles that were
climbing Turtles couldn't get over the
turtle fence and it's really really it's
a great song it's like you know because
it was it was two feet tall so the
turtles couldn't get over is Kamala
gonna climb Biden or the other way
around
[Laughter]
uh John Kirsten says Luke has gone full
Alex Jones
[Music]
[Laughter]
and no
no where are we at dalimar says the
bunny is Cia oh God yeah he was yes he
was Daniel says Phil for two days in a
row good Xmas gift Phil as a fan of Halo
and read the books what was your opinion
of the HALO Series on Paramount uh
terrible it was atrocious I was really
bummed out uh
yeah it was terrible and I was bummed
out mind Fury 1980 says knew Ian is
rolling 20s tonight
where's it where are the dice they're
all done
there's like 12. I was looking for the
20-sided but yeah there's a 20-sided
right there it's gray and they're all
20s
oh yeah there you go no matter what you
do you roll a 20. and then I think that
one's the green one you grab it's like
120-sided die yeah the green and red one
and then those orbs are 100-sided metal
dye that are very heavy I got a bunch of
guitar picks I'm leaving guitar pick too
and there's a ton of rocks everywhere
there there are rocks and he brought an
abacus up here yeah he has a lot of the
loturements but that's right and he has
he has graphene spray
yeah look at it was it graph graphene
Flex spray Don't Spray anything
they're not kidding
that's wild toilet paper I mean I love
you it's giving you a Jason Richardson
Luke again no it's funny if you think
about it Luke has like these Health
drinks
he's got like five different kind of
Health drinks over there and a machete
and then I've actually just got monitors
and uh I got a tech deck over here now
I've got a little fingerboard yeah a
little mini stream Lab yeah
but uh Ian certainly at the new building
we're setting up we're gonna create we
mentioned that's a cafe we're gonna do
Ian's Crystal Cove and it's the first
floor you open the curtains and that's
where the TV and it's like dimly lit and
it'll be like lights everywhere like
creep like you know what I mean like
lava lamp kind of Lights Google up the
uh the scene from uh from Mall Rats
where Brody goes to the dirt mall to
talk to the uh oh talk to the woman the
the three nipple woman and that's the
that's this that's the that's what I
imagine Ian's Crystal Crystal Cove it's
actually a decently large area where
there's like a mezzanine on top so we
have the space underneath where we can
it's big and we're gonna it's like I
don't know like 15 by 15 or like I don't
know it might be like 20 by 20. and so
we're gonna put TVs couches and that's
where you'll chill and drink your coffee
and then you can go upstairs play games
it'll be a lot of fun
all right Strider says Tim the
peripheral was a book first in 2014. in
the book was the jackpot started with
the Texas secessionist movement though
Revolution or whatever
because in the movie I'm sure they take
you know
certain artistic uh leeway if you know
what I mean
all right I can't read your name says
Phil while I know it wasn't written for
it Madness was the official song for the
Afghanistan debacle it got me through
that situation and continues to do so
thank you cool good I it was not written
for it but it probably sums it up pretty
nicely
all right Patriot American says Tim I've
been a fan since 2019 and I've been
thinking about applying for a job at
timcast specifically the gaming team I
have natural experience with writing
game manuscripts and researching what's
needed for the game to succeed I
appreciate it right now we are working
on a roguelike uh platformer-ish kind of
game that uh we really don't have
anybody to hire for right now if that
investment works and the game goes out
and it makes sense then we'll expand and
we'll do more but for the time being we
don't really have much there in that
department
like we haven't even launched anything
yet so you know it is what it is and we
I've talked about like do we hire more
coders and developers and it just like
that wouldn't do anything like you can't
have a bunch of people you know just too
many cooks in the kitchen we're not
making a very complicated game is the
simplest way to put it
all right salty duckling says the Pope's
Omen is code he's trying to tell us that
the world economic Forum people have
revealed the full plan to him and his
can and his conscience had a moment of
guilt he can't say that out loud though
epsteining is a real thing damn but they
wrote books about it too so it's not
it's not like a secret like Klaus
Schwabs literally put out a book called
The Great reset like no the the plans
that they have that everyone's taught
like acts like it's some big secret
conspiracy theory they're so secret they
publish books that you can purchase on
Amazon to find out the the
deep behind the you know behind the
meaning so maybe their goal is if you're
smart enough to read the book you'll be
okay and if you're not smart enough to
read the book welcome to Darwin
it's it's maliciously simple or
deviously simple yeah Wade mekanda says
anyone else noticed that Luke always
rolls a 20.
not always I make mistakes sometimes
everyone does
well I suppose machismo Mojo says Ian is
rolling 20s tonight and then a picture
of a rabbit emoji
Tony says born 1960 we are called
tweeners not Boomers Boomers were of age
to be drafted to Vietnam
interesting
all right Michael says Tim name your
dark coffee am samani it's a chicken
that is black from feathers to bones and
organs also Biden signed an executive
order while saying I don't know what
this says and he was just told to sign
it by Pelosi what for real it happened I
fully believe it yeah me too
yeah that's like the student
cancellation stuff he's like we the bill
passed by just a couple votes like there
there was no bill there was no bill what
are you talking about unite don't fight
says the fourth turning 2028 date
coincides with the biblical date of the
end times the last generation was born
on 3 14 48 when Israel rebuilt itself
fulfilling prophecy a generation is
considered to be 80 years Phil marry me
well that last part was a curveball yeah
out of nowhere what's your name homie
you Knights don't fight no but okay
there you go there you go
Let's see we got Andrew galing says huge
fan Phil I'm currently working on
opening a large music venue and
constantly have your music playing while
I work on this project
cool stuff right on thank you I love you
here we go
Carl Flynn says the rabbit emoji and
elon's tweet wasn't even white it was
Gray
yeah yep good point
yes sir all right Mr duck says Merry
Christmas Happy Hanukkah Festivus buy a
Papa John's Pizza I recommend Mayo on my
pizza keep doing the good work whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa what
Mayo on a pizza
I guess I'm gonna put Ranch on Pizza a
ranch yeah just I mean Mayo is a shock
Mayo just Ranch is basically male I
can't get down with that mayonnaise on
Pizza no you know what I wouldn't but I
would do if you mix mayo and barbecue
together that's what I like doing yeah
what's wrong with mayo on a pizza on a
pizza yeah yeah I would say like like
your sandwiches
but but here's the thing you're saying
no mayo and pizza but if you take Mayo
and sprinkle some like celery salt in it
it's fine
I just wouldn't put mayo on a pizza as a
topping on a pizza no no you dip it
uh I would personally I think that the
flavor of mayonnaise is a little too
bland and pointless for uh so because
Mayo kind of only adds really kind of it
only adds it adds like a texture texture
and it adds some saltiness to your food
mostly like a vinegar yeah a little bit
of vinegar yep acid yeah a little acidic
but like you were talking about Chef
girl said about the eggs and stuff uh
that and that and he that was a stroke
of Genius I want to try it I I've I've
every every breakfast I've had I Splash
a little uh balsamic vinegar so it's
just balsamic right on top of the eggs
no no uh you push the eggs that's what
he said he said push the eggs to the
side and then you've got like because I
cooked the bacon first and then the
bacon on the pan that stuck to it you
Splash a little vinegar scrape it and
mix it around and flip it around and
that's for scrambled eggs yeah okay I
can't even begin to describe how it's
really crazy I'm gonna try it yeah like
it just changes the eggs I can't you
know I'm a fan of vinegar anyways but
back to Mayo on Pizza I I'm not usually
a hater it just surprised me and I
needed I needed a second to absorb it
it's all white pizzas are pretty good
Jonathan Warner says Phil
her this calling you must that on
timcast for two weeks and give us six
more uncensored episodes also when back
in Minnesota I haven't seen you guys
since 93 Fest it's been forever also if
possible tour with Seven Dust all right
I don't think the 93 is accurate
because that was a lot longer
93X Fest or something oh 93X oh yes yes
okay that's a that's a festival okay yes
um I I mean we get up to Wisconsin
whenever we can and uh we've got some
really really phenomenal fans one of the
best shows my entire life was in
Wisconsin
um so I don't know when we'll be out
there but we've got new music coming in
uh in 23 so keep your eyes cool void
Raptor says next year we find out we've
already had the neural link and have
always been in meta I tweeted a joke and
Elon responded with fire emojis so I'll
uh I'll read it for you guys if you
didn't see it uh because people were
saying I was making fun of Elon I wasn't
making fun of Elon I was just kind of
poking fun in general and I guess I was
just generally making fun of people
so uh where's the stupid tweet
I'm digging it's coming up somewhere I'm
looking at my phone uh I said I used to
think Nora link was scary and dangerous
but then Elon Musk bought Twitter and
agreed with me ideologically so now I
think neurolink is great and want to
have my brain plugged into the machine
and then a bunch of people started
commenting and saying things like do you
even actually believe anything and I was
like what are you talking about it's a
it's a [ __ ] post and I was like I love
how people try to find deeper meaning in
[ __ ] posts norlink is awesome I'm
excited to see what it can do to save
lives uh we'll see how it goes with
one-to-one human computer interfacing
that's very far off Elon responded with
fire emojis to the first one and a bunch
of people were like dude he's making fun
of you and I'm like I'm a big fan of
Elon
I'm like just making a joke about
fanboying tribalism but uh uh I I said I
responded in all seriousness I do think
neuralink is great considering the
medical applications but some scary
ethical and philosophical conversations
need to be had 100 but some people
pointed out the end goal is human human
computer interface and I think that is
there's I'm not I'm not outright opposed
to it I do think there are philosophical
and um ethical challenges to get past in
solving for how you do something like
that properly
the issue is just that uh
you can't have a billionaire in control
of it you can't have anyone in control
of it if people are linking their brains
to machines how do you I don't even know
if it's possible to build a system where
there's no centralized control we were
talking about this a little bit last
night and I think that uh
getting that kind of
connection into your brain if it's just
a uh just a interface right so it's
basically takes the place of your thumbs
tapping then I'm not super worried about
it but once you get beyond that once it
gets passed once it gets to the point
where it's beyond just you know that
kind of interface which I I mean you
might argue that they already do already
have that because the they've got uh
monkeys controlling a video game by
their you know using neuralink so maybe
they already have you know they have
like the DNC neuro Lincoln with
fetterman and you know try to figure
that one out well the the the first
application scary once you start really
breaking it down do you want to get so
scary the first the first application
there's no access to any systems outside
but it could correct his brain yeah they
could put the chip on fetterman and
federmen could be talking like normal
and listening like normal it could fix
those things theoretically uh the scary
point is when you get into read and
write mode so you get a you get a Nora
link it's got Wireless
and then someone writes into your brain
changing it and you don't even realize
the the scariest way that I've been able
to conceive it sitting down thinking of
the most terrifying things that I can
come up with is the way that your phone
behaves now right but on steroids so
every time you think a thought because
neuralink ostensibly the idea is it's
able to read your mind right the the
future uh versions of it in the future
every time you think a thought that this
the controller who the power whatever
you know the the bad guy that you're
afraid of whatever dystopian control
you're you're you decide you want to be
worried about every time you think a
thought that that guy approves of the
neural link tells your your dopamine
Center to give you the tiniest little
drop of dopamine that means every time
you think a correct thought you are
unknowingly being conditioned like
Pavlov's dog to have a small
unnoticeable like it would just be oh
I'm in a good mood and if you
consistently have bad thoughts then you
just generally you're kind of in a worse
mood if you consistently have good
thoughts then you're generally in a
better mood and that's literally
controlling your mind just by using the
thoughts that you already think and
giving you a positive reward when you
think of things that they want and a
negative reward or a negative penalty
when you think of things they don't want
you to think and you'd never know it
yeah
you explained it now I imagine the
Chinese would love this well I think and
well if it's able if my wife is able to
program you to take out the trash at a
certain time every day I'm not for it
but she can do that without through
conditioning she can do it yeah I mean
I'm not sure if I'm hearing that request
and I'll register it when I'm she got a
clicker when I'm ready yeah yeah all
right everybody if you haven't already
would you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends become a member at
timcast.com for two reasons first so you
can watch the very cool uncensored
members only show that we'll go up
tonight and also to see a picture of Mr
bocus the cat staring right there with a
with a little bell on and uh he's not
long for this world so you'll be able to
see what we're referring to and uh you
can tell him you can pray for him and
then maybe there'll be a miracle so
smash that like button subscribe to the
channel you can follow the show at
timcastirl follow us on Instagram you
can follow me at Tim Cass and also if
you're on Twitter follow at timcast news
where we post news stories all day every
day and uh you want to shut anything out
yeah uh you all want to learn more about
what I'm doing you can go to
moreforwv.com you can follow me at
rileymord uh WV on Twitter same thing on
Instagram and also Facebook and uh just
thanks for having me on that's been
great yeah right on man absolutely
I am a Phil that remains Phil Labonte I
sing for the band All That Remains you
can check me out on Twitter it's at Phil
that remains uh on Instagram I am at
Phil that remains official uh give me a
follow I'm an interactive kind of guy if
you talk smack I might talk smack back
uh so yeah
good awesome thanks for coming uh this
was a great show really appreciated
everyone's input my YouTube channel is
youtube.com forward slash we are change
today I talked about the Pope's comments
and how he was right especially when it
comes to international relations and the
larger Financial picture I gave examples
of that and then on Luke uncensored.com
I talked about how he was right because
of what's happening with health and our
population check out those videos uh on
we are changed on YouTube and Luke
uncensor.com thank you guys for having
me and I'm serge.com as always at
surge.com everywhere uh thanks been a
good show appreciate it glad to be back
thanks for hanging out everybody we will
see you all over at timcast.com cheers